I don't really know what Rick excels
guess that's the problem
I mean electronics parts reduce Excel
all manner of accessories and doodad for
gadgets RadioShack sells all kinds of
electronic devices and equipment clothes
fits all it pops up and combined well
see this ahh they sound like batteries
batteries
I bought a plug-in adapter from here
several years ago I think that's all I
know about it uh nothing Best Buy
doesn't sell RadioShack has always been
kind of a an impromptu place for me
honestly I'm still surprised at this
store still exists I don't know quite
what itself is different now that I can
get off of Amazon I'd say like diet Best
Buy or low calorie best buy in one word
RadioShack is antiquated RadioShack is
really like local RadioShack is right
across the street from my
RadioShack would be kind of like a last
minute option no Gustad I would feel
terrible
RadioShack went bankrupt it probably
wouldn't affect my life that much
personally I would I don't go there so I
wouldn't feel like there's a void in my
life I just don't really see a point of
a RadioShack
in 2015
[Music]